um thank you for the introduction and uh
thank you for inviting me here um so i'm
going to talk about
efficient algorithms for deep learning
or maybe i should read it efficient
algorithms for deep learning question
mark
because most of this talk will be about
open problems and hardness results and a
few very very few
positive results
okay
this does not work
so
this also does not work
now it works so quickly what what is a
neural networks let's start with a
single neuron
a single neuron has
inputs in this picture five features and
then it has weights v1 to v5
then we just take the inner product
between v and x and
this gives us a scalar and we pass this
scalar through an activation function
sigma which is a function from r to r
usually uh it is
a sigmoidal function
like here
now to construct a neural network you
just stack together many many neurons so
you
wire the output of
neurons to the input of other neurons in
the network uh i'm focusing on
feed forward networks in which there are
no loops in this graph
okay um in this uh
in this picture
there it is a layered network so the
inputs to neuron here comes from the
previous layer but it's not necessarily
so um i will also talk about other types
of networks okay
um so why
should we care about
deep neural networks um
the first explanation and actually this
is the reason i started to think about
neural networks is because some guy a
uses it to do some task b and you should
put in a and b whatever you like
but
maybe this is not a sufficient
explanation so there are classic
explanations because neural networks are
here for a while um and the
classic explanation is that neural
networks are universal approximators
this means that every function
under lipschitz assumption
can be approximated by a neural network
so in a sense uh they are very powerful
um but this explanation is not
convincing
um
why so the first reason it is not very
difficult to show that
for this classic explanation you need a
network of exponent exponential size so
there is no network of polynomial size
that can
approximate every function
okay so why should we care about
networks of exponential size we should
not care about such networks these are
too large for our needs um
and if we're talking about universal
approximators then there are many other
universal approximators all of them will
be exponential in d
um so in my opinion universality is not
interested at all but this is another
story um
so we have nearest neighbor boosting
other so why should we care about neural
networks in particular so before i
i will talk about
how to train neural networks i want to
give few slides about um
why i think that deep neural networks
are great uh from a statistical learning
perspective
okay so so in statistical learning our
goal is to learn a function h from some
domain x
uh i will focus on d dimensional vector
spaces uh to some output y let's talk
about a binary problem so why it's just
0 1
and the input to the learning algorithm
is a training set of m examples and per
example now famous
no freelance theorem
says that any algorithm a and for any
sample size m there is some word
defined by a distribution d over the
product distribution of x and y
and some target function h star
such that h star is very very good with
respect to d so the word is uh
predictable but the algorithm will
fail if the algorithm
receives a training set of m examples uh
its output will be a very bad predictor
with respect to d okay so the problem is
not difficult there is some h star which
is very good but the algorithm will fail
um
and how we circumvent this uh no free
lunch
so we we must have some
bias or prior knowledge about the
problem where we are trying to solve and
we bias the learner toward reasonable
functions and one way to
express it is by a hypothesis class h
which is which is just a subset of all
functions from x to y and we focus on
learning just um such functions and now
the question is what should be h how do
how should we do what how should we bias
ourselves
um so here is the first idea uh recently
david mcallister wrote it in his blog uh
so let let me define h plus plus to be
all function we can implement in c plus
plus
using code lengths of at most b bits
where b is a parameter and then we
sufficiently large b h plus plus
is
excellent a set of functions because
almost whatever we want to to have we
can implement in c plus thrust using big
bits okay
and the sample complexity
meaning how many examples we need to
learn this class uh is nice we it
behaves like a b over epsilon square so
um if we want accuracy epsilon we just
need b over epsilon square examples this
is very easy to prove um
and the learning algorithm is also very
simple here it's just empirical risk
minimization so we just
need to find some c plus plus program
that has minimal error on the training
set and that's it i mean this is what we
want to learn this is how to learn it
and it is the end of the story
of course the problem is a computational
barrier so computationally we have no
idea how to
find a c plus plus program
uh that works well on the training set
we we got okay so the reason to talk
about other hypothesis classes mainly
because of this computational barrier
otherwise this is
an ultimate solution to our problem
so let's uh take a another approach
consider all the functions over
binary but it's also true for non-binary
um spaces that can be executed in time
of at most t of d this is a dimension t
of d is a time where we allow ourselves
for our predictors to run okay so again
um we sufficiently large t of t this is
an excellent class because
uh we want to learn function that we can
run fast okay and you define what is
fast by t of d okay so
it's not a big restriction to learn just
this
class now it is not very difficult to
show that the class of neural networks
of depth
o of t of d
and size o of t of d square
contains all functions that can be
executed on a turing machine in time
t of d so neural networks in that sense
is a great hypothesis class because
again like the c plus plus thing we
before
it enables us to learn efficiently not
efficiently but to learn all the things
that we can actually run
okay so which is what we should care
about
and the sample complexity again a
classic result
appears in the book of peter bartlett
and
from 1999
so the sample complexity behaves nicely
it depends linearly or quadratically on
the size of the network so everything is
again
great
so this is why we should care about
neural networks
of course as before we have we have a
problem how to train neural networks so
we know how to learn
from the statistical point of view just
find a good neural network in the sense
that it behaves nice nicely over the
training set but how can we find
such neural network
so i hope i convinced you that neural
networks are great statistically uh but
the computational barrier is annoying so
it is uh known that
it is hard to learn neural networks to
implement empirical risk minimization is
np-hard and even to approximate it is
np-hard uh and even with very simple
networks of just two layers and three
hidden
um
hidden note layers hidden neurons
in the single hidden layer
sorry
for what loss function even square loss
yes even even for convex loss function
okay um and even in the separable case
so
everything is in your favor and still it
is np-hard uh so what people do uh
usually back propagation which is
gradient descent or stochastic gradient
descent
possibly with some unsupervised
pre-training and other bells and
whistles
but all these methods
while they
sometimes work nicely in practice they
have no
theoretical guarantees and it follows
that if you want to implement it
yourself you need a lot of manual work
okay so
after this long introduction um
this talk is about attempts to
circumvent the
hardness of learning neural networks and
i will talk about the three ideas
the first idea is an idea that jan
lacoon
told me about
in over some dinner uh it calls uh the
idea of overspecification
uh and i will show one result that the
overspecification
works in the sense that it if you
extremely overspecify the network
then you can eliminate local minima
but then i will show a very strong
hardness result
showing that
you need an extreme over specification
and then you lose statistically so
there is no clever trick to make
the over specification work by itself so
we need another idea and the second idea
is to change the activation function so
recall that in neural network we have
inner product with some weights and then
activation function usually taken to be
a sigmoidal function
so maybe we can change the activation
function to be some simpler nonlinear
function and i will talk about the
square function it which is maybe the
simplest nonlinear activation function
i will show a positive result
an efficient algorithm for learning some
product networks so these these networks
are just some intake product because
activation function is square
so depth to and small size uh
some product networks that will show an
efficient algorithm for learning them
this is already a nice achievement
because in the sigmoid sigmoidal
function sigmoidal activation function
i will show you hardness result even for
the two layers and very few number of
hidden neurons
okay on the other hand i will show that
if you want a deeper
much deeper
some product networks it is still very
hard to learn them so we need another
idea so the the last idea is just
imposing some distributional assumptions
and
i will present some work about a
distributional assumption that the
classes lies on algebraic sets
okay so let's start with the first idea
over specification
so uh yandere kun uh told me about the
following experiments that
that
he did
you fix a network architecture
and generate data according to this
network so you know that the networks
comes exactly from some
simple neural network now you
try to apply back propagation in order
to recover the parameters of the wet of
the network uh using the generated data
so this
fails
doesn't work
but if you enlarge the network size you
take
a larger network and then you try to run
back propagation to fit the parameters
of the largest
of the larger network and you only care
not about
recovering the original network you just
care about
having good performance
then this works
okay so the idea here is to to learn
larger networks maybe we will need some
more data to learn these larger networks
but maybe this uh will help us to
circumvent the hardness result
okay so the question is maybe we can we
can efficiently learn your neural
networks using overspecification
um so the first uh i was thinking about
it and the first
thing that
that we came up is that extreme
overspecification actually can give you
a lot
so
if you have a data matrix of m examples
in d dimension
and then you take any a network with say
a capital n internal neurons
v
be all the weights
in the network except
the weights for the last layer
and then f v of x will be the evaluation
of the network
uh
all the all the
internal neurons of the network
over the data matrix okay so this will
be a matrix f okay
and w be the weights of the last layer
so we will predict by taking
w times
f
okay so the theorem tells you that if
you overspecify to the level that the
number of hidden neurons is greater than
or equal to
the number of examples
and under some mild conditions on f that
holds for example if we take sigmoidal
activation functions
then the optimization problem of finding
the weights w and v these are many many
ways to minimize the square error over
the data
has no local
non-global minima so what what do i mean
there are many many many local minima
so there are many many minima so the
this is something like this but all the
local minima are also global minima
okay
so
this is promising because then we can
just apply any gradient descent
algorithm and find some local minima and
then we know that we also have the
global minimite hand
and the idea of the the proof is first
to show that some
with high probability over
small perturbations of the parameters v
then the matrix f
v over x has full rank
um once you have a matrix so this means
that the points in which f has full rank
are dense
and then if you are in such a v then you
can just play with w with the weights of
the last layer and obtain
and you can find the directions that
will decrease the objective meaning that
if you cannot find the direction you
must be in the
global minimum okay
so this is very nice but of course it
has a big problem the number of
neurons here is greater
than greater or equal to the number of
examples so statistically
these such networks will lead to
overfitting
okay
overfitting if our problem is
overfitting maybe there is some clever
way to eliminate over fitting uh like
regularization or people in neural
networks propose dropouts or many many
other ideas
so maybe there is some trick that will
eliminate
this problem
so
what i'm going to show you
is that there is no such trick in the
general case so without more assumptions
no such tricks will work
always
so the theorem is that even if the data
is perfectly generated by a neural
network of depth too
and with only little omega of one
hidden neurons
there is no algorithm that can achieve
small test error
okay so this is a very strong harness
result it means that over specification
dropout regularization
all such attempts are doomed to fail
unless we make more assumptions
um
okay so
how do we prove
such a strong negative result the idea
is to use
hardness result for improper learning so
we can think about the class of neural
networks with two layers
and
and little omega of one hidden neurons
this is a hypothesis class and then we
can ask if there is some algorithm that
can learn it using improper uh
improper
learning and what is improper learning i
will come to it in a moment
um
okay
i will come to it now uh improper
learning is that the learner try to to
learn some hypothesis
h
h star from h in our case h capital h
would be uh the class of neural networks
of depth 2 and little omega of one
hidden neurons
but the learner is not restricted to
output a hypothesis from h you can build
a larger network over specify do
whatever it wants
the algorithm can do everything uh it
just must output a predictor which good
test error okay this is the only
requirement
so how do we show hardness for
for improper learning
so there's a technical novelty in uh in
this lower bound is a new method for
deriving lower bounds for improper
learning it really relies on assumptions
on average case complexity as opposed to
cryptographic assumption which were used
heavily before and this technique
actually yields new hardness results for
other problems like learning dns which
is an open problem since 1989
intersection of little omega of one of
half spaces which immediately gives a
result for neural networks uh
it also helps for agnostically learning
hot space so
it is hard to find a constant
approximate approximation function for
agnostically learning half spaces all of
this comes from the same technique of
proving hardness results using average
case complexity but i will not talk
about it more i will just mention
another corollary of these hard new
hardness results for
problems of
establishing computational statistical
tradeoffs this is probably something
that
you heard
here before maybe in one of my stocks
so
in an upcoming nips paper uh we show
that for the problem of agnostically
learning half spaces over three sparse
vectors you have the following picture
so um statistically you can learn this
problem with order of d examples where d
here is a dimension
but
the naive algorithm takes exponential
time now we show that
if you have less than d to the power of
1.5 examples then no algorithm can learn
it in polynomial time you must have
super polynomial time
but once you have these square examples
then suddenly you can learn it in
polynomial time
and
so this result is uh as far as i know
the first that show it for non-synthetic
problem and together with
lower bounds
so
all of here is d over epsilon square
so i just ignore the dependence on
epsilon fix your epsilon so in in this
graph you fix epsilon you fix it the
target epsilon and then show this graph
okay
okay so the first idea of over
specification is nice but doesn't work
so we need uh other ideas and maybe
combine them together so the second idea
is to change the activation function and
what i will show that together with the
first idea of overspecification
you can you now can learn uh small
neural networks neural networks of depth
2 and a small number of hidden neurons
but i will show that if you want deep
neural networks of
the new activation function it is still
hard okay so
what is some product networks the idea
is to to have simpler non-linearity
instead of sigmoidal function
as activation function we will take
sigma of a to be just a square
okay
so such networks all that what they do
is
something
and
take product of things this is why they
are called sum product networks and
summing and multiplying is uh actually
the way we calculate polynomials so
such networks learn polynomials
um
the size of the networks the um
data the size of the networks as
measured by the number of neurons
determines determines the generalization
properties
and the evaluation time of the network
so we want
to efficiently learn polynomial networks
of small size
so let's start with the smallest
depth possible uh which is not trivial
uh depth to polynomial network so what
we have we we have the input layer then
the hidden layer calculate
v time x square and then the last layer
is just linear function over the hidden
layer okay
so these are the
simplest possible
non-trivial
sum product networks so can we learn
these networks
so what is the hypothesis class
x is mapped to
some functions that depends on two sets
of parameters
lambdas
and
these were where the vi's are vectors
and the lambdas are scalars
it can be shown that
erm
finding the best such
hypothesis
over the training set is still np hard
even though we are with much simpler
non-linearity
but i will show you that here
overspecification
works so if you allow me to learn
slightly larger networks then i can find
a good network efficiently
uh so
the trivial thing to do is just take d
square hidden neurons that will just
take all the products x i x j of two
inputs then it is trivial that it
contains the original network because
this is a
second degree polynomial so if you allow
all monomials of second degree of course
you can learn this
but this leads to a two large networks
the the size of the networks will be uh
d square the question is can we do
better so we want something that will be
roughly the same order of uh
of the number of hidden neurons
so you can do much better by adapting
some greedy algorithm so here is the
algorithm you maintain a matrix v and
the vector lambda the columns of v will
be this vi that defines the
hidden neurons and lambda will be the
weight of the of the last layer um okay
so
you do it in steps at each step you add
one more hidden neuron
so on on step t
you first define this matrix m
this matrix m you can think about it as
some
gradient matrix of the predict of the
current predictor
now
if you find the
largest
eigenvector of the matrix m
so the greedy step is you want a large
gradient so you can think about it like
in peter
peter's talk about coordinate descent
but now we have infinite number of
coordinates and the coordinates are
parameterized by all the vectors all the
vectors
all the unit vectors in rd so finding
the largest
the largest coordinate corresponding to
finding the leading eigenvector of m
then you get a smaller problem of
fitting a small matrix b
uh and minimizing the loss over it this
is a convex optimization problem of
small size so it can be solved easily
and finally we you take you decompose
b2 eigenvectors and eigenvalues and you
construct lambda and v out of it and
iterate
and then the analysis is that if
that if if there is a good small
networks a network of size r where
the size of the lambda i are order of
one then if you overspecify then take a
network of size r square
so square the number of hidden neurons
is over specification then the output of
gecko will be good
so here is an example where over
specification helps
okay
what about a high high degree
polynomials what about depth 3 so it's
still open i don't know to say much i
can tell you
in a theorem that if you want very very
uh deep networks like of of a depth
polynomial in d then this will would be
hard but other constant or
log d it's still open
uh let me rush to the last thing because
i have
five
two more minutes okay two more minutes
um so the last idea is distributional
assumptions and um of course the major
question is what are reasonable
distributional assumptions so here is
one distributional assumption i'm not
sure it's the most reasonable one but
it's something
so
the idea is that we will assume that a
set of positive and negative points are
at least approximately lie on different
algebraic sets so what is an algebraic
set it's just a solution of a set of
polynomial equations so here there is an
ellipse that defines an equation for the
blue and for the red different ellipse
okay so assuming the data is lies on two
different algebraic manifolds can we
train a deep networks that classify the
data and in some sense the answer is yes
and the algorithm is called vanishing
component analysis
very quickly i will
i don't have time to explain the
algorithm but
very quickly maybe i will just say that
we find two sets of
of a polynomials
one set of polynomials uh
gives us all the polynomial behaviors
over the data so this gives us a
representation of all possible
polynomial behaviors over the data the
other set gives us the ideal or all
possible
give us some good representation of all
polynomials that vanishes on the data
and just with these two small sets of
polynomials we can express
the
classification between the two algebraic
sets but unfortunately
i ran out of time so i will skip
the vanishing component analysis part um
i'll just mention maybe very briefly the
analysis so what we build is a set
f1 to ft and v1 to vt and we show that
every polynomial p of the grid d can be
written as g plus h where g is in the
span of these polynomials
and h
is in the ideal generated by these
polynomials so we have a good small
representation for all possible
things that we want to know on this data
and from this we can build a
classification for the two
sets okay
i don't time to compare it to polynomial
kernels so let me just summarize
so deep networks are really great
statistically
but
cannot be trained efficiently and i
think that the main open problem uh for
more rigorous study of of neural
networks is how to find a combination of
network architecture and distributional
assumptions that are useful in practice
and lead to efficient algorithms
and what i showed you is just a few
attempts
i would like to thank my collaborators
so the seek for efficient algorithms for
deep learning is joint work we say oh
hachamere
is a gecko algorithm the greedy
algorithm is together with salon gone a
student of mine and hachamir but it is
based on a previous paper with tong
zhang that is sitting here in natisfebro
the vanishing component analysis is
together with roy livni david lehavi
hilar eliza
and amir globazon
and the lower bounds are joint work with
a student of a joint student of myself
and natalini alami danieli
so thank you for listening
okay
yeah so the guarantee is uh correctness
in this mean usefulness is that if the
if the data lies on different
algebraic sets then you can construct
features just based on these sets f and
v that classif separates the data
so so so uh
just a second so so the efficiency here
is that the number of polynomials in the
worst case will be at most polynomial in
the number of examples n in d uh the the
the problem here is statistical
usefulness so if you happen to find
something with uh little of m
uh components that then you are fine but
can you can we guarantee that always you
can find a little ofm
features no
and a good question here is when can you
guarantee we have some
uh some conditions but
i'm not
i'm still not happy with these
conditions but this is a very good
question
okay let's try again